let's see if we can tackle a slightly
more difficult hyperbola graphing
problem so let's say I have the
hyperbola make this up on the fly X
minus 1 squared over 16 minus y plus 1
squared over let's say 4 is equal to 1
so the first thing to recognize is that
this is a hyperbola and well in a few
videos do a bunch of problems where the
first point is just to identify what
type of conic section we have and then
the second step is to actually graph the
conic section so here when I already
told you that we're going to be doing a
hyperbola problem so you know it's a
hyperbola but the way to recognize that
is you have this minus of the Y squared
term and then we actually have shifted
right the classic or the standard non
shifted form of a hyperbola or a
hyperbola centered at 0 would look
something like this especially if it has
I guess the same asymptotes just shifted
but Center to 0 would look like this x
squared over 16 minus y squared over 4
is equal to 1 and the difference between
this hyperbola and this hyperbola the
center of this hyperbola is at let's see
the center is that the point X is equal
to 1 Y is equal to minus 1 and the way
to think about it is x equals once makes
this whole term 0 and so that's why it's
the center and y equal to minus 1 makes
this whole term 0 and on here of course
the center is the origin Center is 0 0
so the easy way to graph this is to
really graph this one but you shift it
so you're at you're at the you use the
center being 1 minus 1 instead of the
center being 0 0 so let's do that so
let's figure out more about let's figure
out the slope of the two asymptotes here
and then we could we can shift those two
slopes so that it's appropriate for this
hyperbola right here so if we go with
this one
let's just solve for y that's what we
that's what I always like to do whenever
I'm I'm graphing a hyperbola so we get
let's see minus y squared over 4
subtracting x squared over 16 from both
sides minus x squared over 16 plus 1 I'm
working on this hyperbola right here not
this one and then I'm just going to
shift it later and then let's say I
multiply both sides by minus 4 and you
get Y squared is equal to see the minus
cancels out with that and then 4 over 16
is x squared over 4 minus 4 and so y is
equal to plus or minus square root of x
squared over 4 minus 4 and to figure out
the asymptotes you just have to think
about well what happens is X approaches
positive or negative infinity as X gets
really positive or X gets really
negative and we've done this a bunch of
times already and I think this is
important this is more important than
just memorizing the formula cause it
gives you an intuition of where those
equations for the lines of the
asymptotes actually come from because
these are what this graph or this
equation or this function approaches as
X approaches positive or negative
infinity so as X approaches X approaches
positive or negative infinity as X
approaches positive in regular infinity
what is y approximately equal to in this
case well once again this term is going
to dominate this is just a 4 right here
you could imagine when X is like a
trillion or a negative trillion this is
going to be a huge number and this is
going to be just like you know you can
almost fuse like the round off error you
take the square root of that and so this
is going to dominate so as you approach
positive or negative infinity Y is going
to be approximately equal to the square
root the positive and negative square
root of x squared over 4 which so Y
would be approximately equal to positive
or negative what's the square root of
this x over 2 or 1/2 X so let's do that
so let's draw
our asymptotes and remember these are
the asymptotes for this situation but
now of course we're centered at 1
negative 1 so I'm going to draw two
lines with these slopes at with positive
1/2 and negative 1/2 slopes but they're
going to be centered at this point
because I'm using I just got rid of the
shift just so I could figure out the
asymptotes but of course this is the
real thing that we're trying to graph so
let me do that see so this is my x-axis
my y-axis sorry this is my x-axis and
the center of this is that 1 negative 1
1 negative 1 so X is equal to 1 Y is
equal to minus 1 fair enough
and then the slopes of the asymptotes
were positive and negative 1/2 right
positive and negative 1/2 so let's do
the positive 1/2 so that means for every
2 you run over so if you if you go
positive in the positive x-direction -
you move up 1 so you go to the right -
and up 1 so that's the first one let me
draw that asymptote it looks something
like that and then let me draw it from
this point to that point then I have a
steady hand ok there you know I get the
point
and then the other asymptote is going to
have a minus 1/2 slope so if I take if I
remember this is our Center 1 - 1 so if
I go down 1 and over so when I go over 2
I go down 1 so that'll be right there
let me draw those asymptotes like that
asymptote it's going to look like that
and then just to continue it in the
other direction it's going to look and I
want to make it the lines overlap it
looks something like that so we've drawn
our asymptotes for this function and now
we have to figure out it's going to be a
kind of a vertical hyperbola or a
horizontal hyperbola now the easy way to
think about it is is to try to make and
we can do it two ways I mean if you just
look at this equation right here when
you're taking the positive square
route we're always going to be slightly
below the asymptote right the asymptote
is this thing but we're always going to
be slightly below it so that tells us
that we're always going to be slightly
below the asymptote on the positive
square root and we're always going to be
slightly above the asymptote on the
negative square root because it's going
to be a little less and it's negative
but I'll let you think about that so I
already tell you know my intuition is
going to be there and there it's more
than intuition I know that we're going
to be a little bit less than the
negative square root but I'll do it the
other way I'll do it the way I did in
the last video so the other way to think
about it is what happens when this term
is here for this term to be 0 X has to
be equal to 1 and does that ever happen
can X be equal to 1 if X is equal to 1
here this term is 0 and then you have a
situation where see if X is equal to 1
this is 0 and then you have a minus y
squared over 4 would have to equal 1 or
this would have to be a negative number
so X could not be equal to 1 so Y could
be equal to negative 1 let's try that
out
if Y is equal to negative 1 let's try
out that point if Y is equal to negative
1 this this term right here disappears
right when Y is equal to negative 1
you're negative 1 negative 1 plus 1
that's 0 0 4 so when y is equal to
negative 1 you're just left with I'll do
it down here well I don't want you're
left with X minus 1 squared over 16 is
equal to 1 right I just cancelled out
this term come saying what happens when
y is equal to negative 1 you multiply
both sides by 16 you get let me do it
over here these get messy X minus 1
squared is equal to 16 take the square
root of both sides X minus 1 is equal to
positive or negative 4 and so if X is
equal to positive 4 if you add 1 to that
X would be equal to 5 right and then if
X if X minus 1 would be minus 4 and you
add 1 to that you would have X is equal
to 3 so our two points are I guess you
can kind of our two points closest to
our Center are the points
five comma negative one and three comma
negative one and let's plot those two so
five one two three four five negative
one and three negative one is that right
so oh no minus three so because X minus
1 could be minus four that's what
happens when you skip steps and if you
have minus one plus let me write that so
X minus one is either equal to 4 or X
minus one is equal to minus 4 if you
have the minus four situation then X is
equal to minus three so you go you go
one two three minus three minus one so
those are both points on this hyperbola
and then our intuition was correct or at
least what I said that we're always
going to be below the positive the
positive square root is always going to
be slightly below the asymptote so we
get our curve is going to look something
like this it's going to get closer and
closer and then here it's going to get
closer and closer in that direction it
keeps getting closer and closer to that
asymptote and here it's going to keep
getting closer and closer to the
asymptote on that side and then on that
side and of course these asymptotes keep
going on forever and forever and if you
want you could try out some other points
just to confirm you could plot that
point there or that plot point there
just to confirm that that's the case the
hard part really is is just to identify
the asymptotes and just to figure out do
we sit kind of on the left and the right
or do we sit on the top and the bottom
and then you're done you you can graph
your hyperbola see in the next video